[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi avec 4
octobre
spirou et fantasio boulard les profs
encore les tuniques bleues le monde de
la bd sera réunie ce week-end à but pour
la 24e édition du festival pour en
parler le maire de la commune jean marc
régulier et marc donne l'un des
dessinateurs de michel vaillant 92
artistes 49 lieu 29 communes les 7 et 8
octobre c'est la 13e édition du parcours
ateliers d'artistes le public est invité
à découvrir les talents
yves les noirs et essonniens la grande
valse brillante est une plongée absurde
dans une institution totalitaire et
délirante le collectif thermos le joue
pour la première fois à la ferme de bel
ébat à guyancourt
il a presque un quart de siècle et
accueille chaque année des centaines de
passionnés le festival de la bd revient
à but pour sa 24e édition est avec nous
au plateau ce soir jean-marc le rudulier
maire de vic pour soir et marburg jeudi
l'un des dessinateurs de michel vaillant
au sol alors première question je veux
me tourner vers vous monsieur régulier
pour cette édition encore une
programmation riche et dense comme
d'habitude une programmation riche et
dense beaucoup de beaucoup de jeunes
beaucoup d'anciens de nombreux
dessinateurs qui sont venus durant ces
24 des fidèles
et puis des nouveaux des nouveaux alors
il ya des dessinateurs de francs
d'europe enfin de prendre d'europe de
russie de tchétchénie aussi on a donc je
pense que cette année on va faire on
vise effectivement le 25e
mais déjà pour le 24e je pense qu'on va
faire un nombre important de visites
pour se battre oui c'est vrai que
l'année dernière l'année d'avant c'était
similé dernière cet échec 1500 environ
j'en ai discuté tout à l'heure avec ma
directrice des affaires culturelles qui
m'a dit rond on va faire les 10000
ouvert à l'amour mais on a une grande
une grande publicité qui fait au niveau
de la ville de paris finit qui s'étant
beaucoup à travers la sncf à travers la
ratp et je pense que tout ça c'est très
porteur finalement et puis le cadre
l'écrin dans lequel se déroule ce
festival c'est quand même le château
rebut crié tu es une des pièces
maîtresses d'un album de sos météores
blake et mortimer blake et mortimer sos
bien tout ça mais ça fait que nivet fait
qu'on reste dans l'univers de la bande
dessinée
justement on disait tout 7500 passionnés
l'an dernier les pollens les portes du
château ouvre à 10 heures officiellement
j'imagine qu'à du monde
longtemps avant alors l'année dernière
il paraît parce que j'y suis pas allé
j'aimerais bien les voir mon bon à 3
heures du matin il ya des gens qui sont
de 1 à 6 le long de la rue puisque le
parc fermé qui ont leurs petits sièges
ils ont ils ont tout sur leur matériel
les dernières je suis pleuvaient en plus
alors là c'est passé par hasard quand il
fait beau ou encore mais il y a des
idées des bédéphiles est vraiment un
grand passionné qui
n'hésite pas à se lever de très bonne
heure pour être les premiers sur le site
à l'ouverture à 10h on a parlé des
passionnés mais du côté des auteurs marc
bonne pour nous par donc ça rendez vous
à ne pas manquer j'irai pour moi oui
puisque je suis un jeu fait partie des
fidèles du festival parce que j'ai fait
du dessiner la fiche du la deuxième
édition en 95 et depuis j'y suis allée
près quasiment tous les ans nous faut
dire je suive linois donc pour moi c'est
un peu un voisin un régional de l'étape
et justement ça arrange et avoir un tel
festival dans son département
ah oui ça c'est vraiment c'est bien
c'est important il ya eu il ya eu un
festival à versailles d'une ou deux
années mais on peut considérer que oui
que bucs c'est l'un des plus gros
festivals de la région parisienne et
c'est le un festival qui est
indispensable dans les yvelines où c'est
sûr parce qu'il ya des amateurs de
bandes dessinées dans les vignes et des
auteurs aussi et donc
donc c'est vraiment bien qu'ils aient ce
festival haut et ça c'est indispensable
dans les yvelines soir mon avis alors
dans votre bédéthèque vous êtes l'auteur
de barberousse la dernier des mohicans
les pirates de barataria si je me trompe
pas et michel vaillant comment est-ce
qu'on en vient à dessiner le plus
célèbre des pilotes français ainsi
l'éditeur qui m'avait qui m'avait
demandé alors je suis l'auteur des
quatre derniers albums de barbe rouge
mais je suis pas je suis pas le créateur
de la série
j'ai repris cette série par l etat les
démocrates et une adaptation en bande
dessinée que j'ai fait avec avec mon ami
marcel uderzo et michel vaillant c'est
une reprise également sur une même dans
une vieille série qui avait 70 albums
c'est l'éditeur qui m'a demandé qui m'a
contacté qui m'a demandé si ça
m'intéressait de la reprendre
sachant que j'étais un fan de la série
est ce qu'il vous plaît chez michel
vaillant le personnage la vitesse moi je
suis un passionné de course automobile
on l'est tous d'ailleurs tous les
auteurs de là
la série philippe graton et denis
lapière les scénaristes et benjamin
benéteau qu'ils destinent eric monnet 2
à dessiner on est tous des passionnés de
courses automobiles et et 2 de la série
michel vaillant elle même de créer par
jean graton de son univers de ces
personnages là l'ambiance familiale et
puis le côté effectivement très branché
sur l'actualité du sport automobile
dernier oui c'est un album qui se
déroule pendant les 24 heures du mans et
on est donc on était allé en repérage
toute l'équipe on est allé en repérage
au mans il ya un an on a fait avec
benjamin a dû faire un millier de photos
comme on fait en général quand on est en
repérage
et puis ce qui est merveilleux quand on
est en repérage dans le milieu du sport
automobile pour michel vaillant c'est
que toutes les portes s'ouvrent c'est
une série ken telle notoriété auprès des
amateurs de f1 et mer auprès des
professionnels du sport de vivre qu'on
peut rencontrer tout le monde moi j'ai
rencontré alain prost j'étais content de
mes idoles et et puis on y retourner
cette année avec l'album donc un an pour
faire un album est donc l'album se
déroule aux 24 heures du mans le dernier
album s'intitule e rébellion à découvrir
rencontrer alors un autre artiste
présent ce week-end qui est bien connu
aussi des bédéphiles erreur puisque
l'auteur des profs et de boule à un
auteur à succès qui vient de sortir le
dix neuvième tome de sa saga
le festival est un rendez vous régulier
pour lui et côté je vais chaque année
depuis déjà un certain temps c'est assez
sympa parce que déjà je retrouve j'aime
bien les gens qui le met en forme qui
s'en occupe c'est important dans un
festival de bd il faut il ya plusieurs
choses il faut être s'y sentir bien
qui est du monde qui est quand même un
certain qu'ils aient du lectorat parce
que sinon ça sert à rien on s'ennuie et
qu'on ait plaisir de retrouver les
copains enfin voilà et là en
l'occurrence sa réunie à peu près toutes
ces conditions
jean marc larre aux idées on l'a entendu
et rock félicite notamment
l'organisation
c'est une grosse équipe oui non c'est
pas une très grosse équipe justement bon
le service culturel de la mairie ces
trois personnes il ya beaucoup de
bénévoles en fait et en particulier à un
grand bénévole c'est
jean-claude mirman jean-luc gens lui
demandent
[Musique]
l'institut allons 93 il nous avait
envoyé un magnifique courrier et puis
c'est de là qu'est née la bd en fait en
94 et puis effectivement comme on a
parlé tout à l'heure il ya eu il ya eu
des essais d'autres festina versailles
mais du fait que maintenant on travaille
dans l'intercommunalité c'est le même
territoire versailles but on a eu des dd
entretien avec le maire de versailles
avec les maires de viroflay aussi il y
avait des tendances pour pour dire que
ont fait une bd sur le territoire on
fait un salon sur le territoire et on a
conservé ce on a eu la chance de
constater qu'ils avaient conservée là on
est un peu pris par le temps où je dois
juste qu'on fasse un petit mot sur la
fiche de cet alex que vous le faites se
faire par des dessinateurs qui se
déplace et cette année il ya deux
enfants bien turbulent comme tom et nana
c'est tom tom et nana elle s'essaiera
et bernadette després qui a
accepté très gentiment d'ailleurs de
nous faire la fiche est qui qui attire
qui va attirer beaucoup d'enfants je
pense je pense que c'est une
dessinatrice l'a commencée en 73 presque
s'adresse aux enfants alors est ce
festival
ah oui ah ben oui aux enfants à tout le
monde en fait aux enfants ou aux grands
la bdc de 6 comme tintin c'est un peu de
cette c2 général soit 1,19
je dois vous couper ce qu'on est très en
retard merci à tous les deux de vous
êtes déplacé sur ce plateau pour aller
vous mon pour aller à la rencontre de
vos auteurs favoris
rendez vous au château de buc les 7 et 8
octobre on parle maintenant à guyancourt
où la ferme de bel ébat propose une
création la grande valse brillante mise
en scène par le collectif tarnos huit
comédiens 19 personnages
reportage
[Musique]
au lendemain de beuvry pour simon le
jeune historien ne sait pas où il est
mais le voilà interne est monté par le
collectif thermos la grande valse
brillante est une pièce de drago yanchak
écrite en 1985 il s'agit de
l'établissement
on va dire lambda
dans un premier temps et donc d'un
système qui fonctionne avec différentes
différentes fonctions emblématiques de
l'ordre du politique du religieux
et à l'intérieur de ce système il ya des
rouages
qui vont qui vont se mettre à a déraillé
pour le bien ou pour le mal de
l'ensemble l'ensemble du groupe humain
qui dit
[Musique]
les regarder
et première vue c'est un cas plutôt
difficile
une pièce encore d'actualité où le
public et les artistes font un tout un
trois fronts pour que l'action soit
partout la mise en scène veut faire
réagir et ne s'inquiète pas de
de commandites quatrième mur dans la
mesure où si je pose cette interrogation
l'amant aujourd'hui sur ce plateau
c'est forcément une c'est forcément une
interrogation et une situation qui me
dérange
ça veut dire que moi je peux pas rester
confortablement assise dans mon fauteuil
à regarder les choses comme si j'en
faisais pas moi même partie donc moi je
vais être moi-même mal à l'aise en fait
de miroirs ou mais en fait là quelqu'un
qui est en train de se faire humilier
devant moi et je bouge pas et je bouge
pas parce que je suis spectatrice huit
comédiens sur scène mais 19 personnages
pour dénoncer une violence du pouvoir
la grande valse brillante et pour la
première fois créé en france on poursuit
cette culture avec notre nouvel invité
calme où tout est beau jour vous êtes
jeune artiste peintre et sculptrice vous
faites partie des 92 artistes qui
participent au 13e parcours d'artiste
d'hélium alors certains ouvrent leur
atelier d'autres exposent c'est votre
cas à la maison des bonheurs de manière
on y découvre votre univers est
particulièrement l'enfant c'est bien ça
notamment j'ai essayé dans ce parce que
j'ai pu montrer cette année sur ce
parcours de montrer un peu le champ une
sorte de résumé de ce que j'ai pu faire
j'ai assez longtemps travaille
effectivement sur l'enfant et le très
jeunes enfants même
mais je me suis pas arrêté à ça et aussi
bien mon champ de techniques montchamp
d'inspiration jeudi est plus large que
simplement l'enfant est assez présent
vous avez des sculptures qu'est ce qui
vous inspire c'est l'innocence c'est la
naissance que nous achevions inspire
chez les français c'est sa morphologie
en fait ce sont ces cours qui soit à la
fois rondes et douces
voilà et en fait on peut être chez
enfants rond est beau et ça ça ne dure
pas toute la vie voilà arrivé comment et
puis bien sûr il ya aussi que j'ai eu
aussi ce souci de de faire une sculpture
ou du dessin savons assez sensible et
qui sont porteurs d'un message quand
même assez rien de gore rien de triste
rien d'affreux j'avais moi je suis
attaché à ce qui est ce qui nous ferait
du bien on va dire vous êtes vos tons
pastels pour gagner et garder cette
douceur alors des tons des tons pastels
si j'avais vu ça refuge pour les enfants
c'est vrai on est obligé d'être très
doux et après quand on sait à toucher au
corps humain plus âgés on peut obliger
de se limiter à la palette douce voilà
justement le corps plus plus plus adulte
vous travaillez pas à travers des
courbes et rondeurs des courbes
féminines principalement
oui en fait c'est un peu près trois
quatre ans j'ai fait
du modèle vivant de façon beaucoup plus
intense et je me suis rendu compte je me
pratique et ça à rambouillet je me suis
rendu compte que en me mettant dans des
situations inconfortables avec manque de
temps manque de manque d'installations
en prenant par exemple sa mauvaise main
parce que je suis très droitière dit
voilà on me mettant dans mon inconfort
j'arrivais à obtenir des résultats
complètement différent très loin de la
maîtrise je dirais habituel et que nos
ressortait quelque chose de plus
expressif beaucoup moins contrôlé mais
beaucoup plus riche en émotions en fête
est donc maintenant depuis trois quatre
ans j'ai tout en continuant je dirais
sur la veine réaliste et fidèle et
sensible par ailleurs j'essaye aussi de
développer une expression beaucoup plus
lâches et où il ya un peu de perte de
maîtrise volontaires
voilà et quand vous développer
différentes techniques parce que
montpellier mais vous sculptez aussi
vous n'avez pas de domaine de
prédilection c'est que votre imagination
a besoin de ressortir dans ses
différents oui j'ai toujours eu
je n'ai jamais pu choisir une seule
technique ce qui voulait dire abandonner
les autres parce que on va dire que
principalement ce que j'aime c'est le
défunt que le dessin et partons il
aidera sculpture il est dans l'aquarelle
il est vraiment temps toutes les
techniques
il est même dans l'art abstrait le
dessin est
oui du coup j'ai un petit peu du mal à
me cerner moi-même entre tous qui est
très illustratif comme la série des
petits sourit en ce moment où très
expressif comme les grands nus en
passant par lé donc les deux travaillent
à ses fidèles sur la petite enfance
d'être éclectique techniquement ça ça
fait qu'on ait toujours un petit peu
frais quand on arrive sur un travail
puisqu'on a pour ne pas de l'institut
technique et bientôt celle que présente
sont haletantes 50 en ulm
peut-être que les états voisins bretons
ne vous ai donné des cours et dans
différentes comme délavées l'on peut
voir certaines de vos sculptures
notamment à voisins aussi puisque vous
avez fait l'aviatrice hélène boucher là
aussi enfants oui abb 1
c'est une petite fille 7 8 ans à peu
près oui voilà donc c'est vrai qu'elle
est c'est une figure un voisin hélène
boucher à la volée la pauvre elle se
situer là c'était un parcours
extraordinaire cette femme voilà mai
oui mais voilà mon dieu j'y suis depuis
bientôt 30 ans donc voilà j'ai créé de
patates a donc c'est votre âne ateliers
pour adultes des passionnés viennent de
faire du dessin du raku de la sculpture
l'aquarelle façon hebdomadaire est cuit
puis on fait face et richelieu ont fait
des stages en fermant ça fait longtemps
ça fait 25 ans dans cinq ans alors
hélium vous êtes posé qu'une autre
artiste yvelinoise pas tout seul dans
dans à la maison des bonheurs daniela
coelho alors elle travaille dans un
style plus expressionniste abstrait
beaucoup leur très prononcé là cette
fois elle est aussi professeure d'arts
plastiques aux conservateurs de plaisir
c'est l'organisation que vous avez vous
rencontrez vous connaissez déjà
on se connaissait absolument pas avec
daniela dont moi j'ai découvert et
daniela et son univers et qui est dedans
si c'était une bonne association parce
qu'on fait tellement pas les mêmes
choses
j'ai les traits coloriste voilà parce
qu'on tient son peps à peut-être sonné
mais elles n'ont pas de douceur non plus
d'années c'est juste un univers
absolument différent j'étais grand arbre
de vie
c'est vraiment une grande variation de
deux touches colorées
je pense qu'on en parle aurait dit
faible que moi mais vraiment vous venez
d'avoir les lavoirs et il reste encore
un des deux week-ends d'hélium pour
aller visiter aujourd'hui personne
n'aura la maison des bonheurs donc pour
découvrir vos havre avoue camille tout
et est celle de daniela coelho alors
montré il ya ceux qui exposent vous les
rencontrerez vous rencontrerez public
d'ailleurs ce week-end et il ya aussi
les artistes qui ouvrent leur atelier
c'est le cas de patrick pogu il
travaille il vit à magny les hameaux et
fait découvrir ses oeuvres au chalut
dans son atelier et aquarelliste pardon
les images sont si nicolas d'embûches
[Musique]
il
son sourire vous accueille un
autoportrait fait au café patrick pogu
peint depuis une quinzaine d'années une
passion de l'art est un coup de foudre
pour l'aquarelle en particulier le
travail de l'eau c'est à dire que je
mouille toute la feuille de papier avant
de commencer et je mets mes pigments et
il ya toujours un côté très aléatoire
dans ce type de travail
ce qui fait que ça m'aide à être un peu
plus créatif que si je travaillais dans
la crise hydrique
je vais avoir ce qu'on appelle deux
heures d'ouverture c'est à dire que je
vais pouvoir travailler mon aquarelles
pendant deux heures en gardant un bon
niveau d'humidité sur la sur la feuille
[Musique]
voilà des toiles peintes au gré des
voyages patrie pogu ne s'impose pas de
thème il veut peindre son vécu
l'aquarelle lui donne une sensation
d'immédiateté dans l'aquarelle
il est très difficile de faire de belles
retouches donc il faut à la fois tout
avoir prévu à l'avance sachant que ça va
se passer différemment
envoyez là là on commence à voir ce qui
est intéressant c'est tous ces pigments
qui dans l'eau prennent une ne restent
pas là où j'ai posé le pinceau sa
continuent à fuser
cet artiste amateur est un autodidacte
il a choisi de partager sa passion en
ouvrant les portes de son atelier le
week-end prochain
40 artistes en neuf ans accueillis par
la médiathèque antoine de saint-exupéry
à voisins le bretonneux le projet
artistes d'ici connaît une nouvelle
étape
une sorte de rétrospective ou 25 de ces
artistes sont à nouveau invités
aurélie ronces
[Musique]
est des traditions marocaines peinte par
fatima binet à la ville de pierre richir
la médiathèque à voisins le bretonneux
rassemble des artistes yvelinois l'idée
c'était de se faire rencontrer tout ce
qu'on avait vu ça faisait à peu près
quatre ou cinq expositions par an l'idée
c'était de blocs trouver tous les
univers en une seule exposition bon pour
un final pour un dernier finale une
rétrospective d'artistes d'ici
rassemblant 25 créateurs parmi la
quarantaine qui a accueilli la
médiathèque on trouve à la fois de la
sculpture la photographie la peinture
alors la peinture la fois du jeu
l'aquarelle du pastel de l'huile donc
voilà c'est pareil pour la sculpture
avec des supports complètement différent
la fois de la pierre mais aussi du bois
du bois flotté et puis on a une
céramiste donc qui qui a exposé aussi
[Musique]
l'exposition s'accompagne d'ateliers
d'écriture par les itinéraires poétique
pour pourquoi pas écrire l'histoire de
ces chercheurs d'espoir de collines
hubert
besoin d'un conseil avant de vous rendre
dans les salles obscures luc beaucamp à
deux rendez vous à vous proposer écouter
coup de coeur du ciné cette semaine
c'est un petit peu original ça sera un
peu des sentiers battus c'est le film
les fiancés en folie de buster keaton
qui ressort en version totalement
restaurée 4k donc très forte qualité
d'image et donc qu'on diffuse notamment
dimanche à 18h30 pour fêter un petit peu
la rentrée fêtait début d'un cycle
keaton qui va se dérouler tout au long
du mois d'octobre alors le pitch très
rapide
comme d'habitude chez buster keaton
c'est complètement désopilant c'est
l'histoire d'un type qui apprend
incidemment que pour hériter d'une
immense fortune
il a une journée pour se marier voilà
donc évidemment les prétendantes vont se
faire très nombreuses et ça va être une
espèce de course poursuite pour
peut-être qu'on ait chevet est
complètement délirante jusqu'à la fin de
cette journée je vous en dis pas plus
voilà je ne peux pas terminer sans citer
non plus à la fiche du ciné cette
semaine
la suite c'est pas vraiment une suite la
prolongation du film mythique culte
blade runner donc blade runner 2049 de
denis villeneuve que nous avons sur nos
écrans que j'ai pas encore vu dont je ne
peux pas vous en parler les venez voir
je pense que ça vaut quand même le coup
d'après ce que j'ai entendu
ils jouent leur tout premier concert à
devait pourtant ils ont déjà une grande
carrière johnny c'est jamieson la voix
gospel du duo a travaillé qu'elton john
et de georges et jean jacques goldman
michael hester a fait les premières
parties de chuck berry et était le
guitariste de johnny hallyday ils seront
aux clayes-sous-bois ce vendredi avec
leurs morceaux rock aux influences des
années 70 avec nissan avant d'écouter un
bout de leur culte je veux pas que ça
soit quelque chose qu'ils deviennent nos
qui amène une sorte de nostalgie
je veux que ça sera quelque chose
nouveau à malgré quelques petites
influence certes mais nouveau je veux
pas vraiment garder mes coups de sac
olala ça me fait penser le bon vieux
temps non je pour moi c'est juste la
musique comme la musique et qui dégage
quelque chose assez sûr qu'ils dégagent
une force un peu c'est pas une fausse la
joie bien sûr
[Musique]
ce que deux
gc
[Musique]
les nous c nous brice de nice fais pas
ci fais pas ça et la scène avec au fric
bruno salomone il montre une autre
facette de son talent 43 personnage
raconte l'histoire de galeries l'enfant
né en riant bande annonce c'est
l'histoire d'un homme comme les autres
car il était madame chimay maladie
galerie qui est le géniteur
bon j'avoue me la piste aux étoiles je
fais la pieuvre et le corps et les
répète qu'un bon petit spectacle
rafraîchissant avec un professionnel du
divertissement à la batterie le
guyancourt toi caso fête le premier
anniversaire de son album de paris à
maurice cette occasion il invite sur
scène tonton david caporal nigga et des
invités surprises
extraits
[Musique]
le seul truc que tu aurais maintenant
terminer je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis à mercredi prochain
[Musique]